كدمات وممزقة ومنتفخة، هذه هي
يدي نيم أبوراس بعد
اعتقاله لمدة 5 أيام من قبل
القوات الإسرائيلية، جروحه ليست فريدة من نوعها في هذه
الزاوية من مستشفى الشهيد في غزة،
هنا ستة صبية وأربعة رجال
كانت أيديهم مرقمة بعلامة حمراء.
عولجوا بعد ساعات من إطلاق القوات الإسرائيلية
سراحهم دون تهمة. محمود يبلغ من
العمر 14 عامًا فقط. اعتقله
الجنود الإسرائيليون هو ووالده في
حي ألون بمدينة غزة، حيث
يخوض الجيش الإسرائيلي
قتالاً عنيفًا مع
حماس، وكان
محمود ووالده من بين المئات.
من الأولاد والرجال الفلسطينيين، تم تحديد العديد منهم
من قبل أقاربهم أو
أصحاب العمل على أنهم مدنيون تم
تعصيب أعينهم وجردوا من ملابسهم واحتجزوا خلال
الأسبوع الماضي.
وصف 10 فتية والرجال الذين تحدثوا إلى CNN روايات متطابقة تقريبًا عن
الانتهاكات، وقال العديد منهم إنه لم يُسمح لهم
بالذهاب  أجبر على النوم على
حبات الأرز المتناثرة على الأرض ولم
يُقدم له سوى القليل من الطعام أو
الماء بعد يوم من وصوله إلى
المستشفى. محمود عاصم، البالغ من العمر 40 عامًا، بالكاد يستطيع
تحمل يقول أقاربه إنه مصاب بالسكري
ولا يستطيع الوصول إليه  تلقى الأنسولين خلال
اعتقاله لمدة 5 أيام، في بيان
قال الجيش الإسرائيلي إنه يحتجز
أفرادًا يشتبه في تورطهم في
نشاط إرهابي، وأنه يتم إطلاق سراح أولئك الذين
يتبين أنهم لا يشاركون في
أنشطة إرهابية،
وقال جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي إن الأفراد المحتجزين
يعاملون وفقًا لـ
القانون الدولي وأنها تسعى جاهدة إلى معاملة أي
معتقل بكرامة، وأي حادث
لم يتم اتباع المبادئ التوجيهية فيه
سيتم النظر فيه عندما
رفض متحدث باسم الجيش الإسرائيلي تناول
مزاعم محددة عن سوء المعاملة أو
تقديم تفسير لاحتجاز
الصبية العشرة و  الرجال الذين أجرت CNN مقابلات معهم،
كان القانون الدولي واضحًا تمامًا
أنه لا يمكنك احتجاز المدنيين إلا عند
الضرورة القصوى
لأسباب أمنية قهرية، سواء
كان الاحتجاز لمدني أو
لمقاتل، يحمي القانون
المحتجزين والمحتجزين من
المعاملة المهينة والاعتداءات
الشخصية.  كرامة أحمد البالغ من العمر 14 عامًا،
الصدمة ليست
جسدية فقط، بإذن والده، فهو
يضيف قصته إلى مزاعم
الاعتداء على
جيريمي دايموند سي إن إن بالقرب من حدود إسرائيل وغزة